FEMALE SPEAKER: So thank you
everybody for being here today.
We're all very excited
to welcome a great chef
to the Google office.
He just released a new
cookbook, which, if you want,
is back over on that table.
You can see it up here.
He's going to be demoing
two recipes for us, the crab
cakes and the pumpkin salad.
So if you have questions,
we'll do a Q&A towards the end.
But throughout, just
enjoy, learn, and have fun.
So thank you.
JEREMY SEWALL: Thanks.
So both these recipes
are in the book.
And they're really very easy.
And I encourage people
to-- if you like food,
I always encourage people to
get outside your comfort zone
once in a while and do something
you've never done before.
And these a really easy
recipes that are pretty doable.
I think with a little
bit of patience,
a good bottle of wine, and some
time, you can figure these out.
And they're very
seasonal, so this
is from the fall
section the book.
It's with pumpkins.
Obviously, pumpkins you see
everywhere now to nauseum.
Every store has a pumpkin.
The smaller ones are
called sugar pumpkins.
And they're a
little bit sweeter.
They're really good.
And the lettuce
we're going to use
is called frisee, which
is a little bit bitter.
It's a little hearty lettuce.
It's In the chicory family.
It's got a sweet bitterness
to it, which is really good.
And then ricotta cheese and
a real simple vinaigrette.
And I'll explain each
section as we go along.
And then we'll get to taste it.
Everyone as a kid,
you carved pumpkins.
You got the top out.
You scooped the seeds out.
And you toast the
seeds, hopefully.
But I'm just going
to show you the chef
way, how you tackle pumpkin.
They can be really delicious.
So, really easy,
just cut the top off.
We cut the bottom off.
And really, that's
just so it sits flat
so it doesn't wobble
too much on you.
And everyone should have
one of these in their house.
It's a really good vegetable
peeler, really heavy-duty,
really sharp,
really a great thing
to have around for shaving
cheese or anything.
And these are strong
enough-- those actually
peel a pumpkin--
thanks very much.
And this is a lot easier
than trying to take a knife
and peel it from the outside.
It's lot safer.
You peel the pumpkin like
you're peeling an apple.
It's a little thicker
skin, and sometimes you've
got to go over it twice.
But that just gives you an
idea of how easy that can be.
Just peel it all the way down.
So I'm not going to
peel the whole thing.
But that just gives you an idea.
And then we're going to cut it.
And then for this recipe I cut
it in, usually, four or six.
This is a little bit
bigger, so we could probably
cut it into six.
But first we cut it
in half, then in half.
And what we want to do is
just scrape the seeds out.
And there's
actually-- you can see
there's a lot of
seeds in a pumpkin.
And they're really delicious.
So you just scrape it all out.
And then from that
part, what we end up
doing is, before we
cook it, from here what
we do is take this
piece, cut that in half.
And then we just cut it into
little wedges like this.
And then from here-- you
can see how easy that is.
From here, we just toss
these in a little olive oil,
and we bake them.
And this is what they
look like at the end.
Now, you don't want to bake
them so much that they're mushy.
But they're soft, so you can
eat them cold in a salad.
And they pick up the
flavor really nice.
And they have great
flavor, great color.
They're a really
beautiful, autumn color.
So that's what that looks like.
And then the seeds-- a
little bit of the trick
is if you actually
scrape all the seeds,
and then you put this in
water and just mix it around,
all the seeds separate
from everything else.
And you just peel
them off the top.
Once you get the seeds
and you rinse them off--
and you see how
easy they separate.
And you rinse them
off, and you dry them.
And then we toss them in
a little bit of butter
and toasted cardamom.
And you toast them.
And that's what
they come up with.
They're just really little
crunchy pumpkin seeds.
They're absolutely delicious,
and it's really easy.
So to make the
salad, again, it's
just simple autumn
salad, our frisee.
And that's the root, where it
grows in the ground like that.
Just trim that end off.
Trim a little off the top, where
it might be a little wilted
or beat up from handling.
And then I just cut in half.
I'm just going to spread out.
Oh my God, it's so easy.
So here it is, our roasted
pumpkin, our frisee.
And this vinaigrette
is we took curry.
And we put dried curry
powder in a dry saute pan.
And you put it on a low heat.
And you toast the curry.
And as it starts
to get hot, it'll
start to change the flavor.
And you'll smell this
great toasted curry aroma.
And as soon as you
start to smell and see
that toast a little bit,
you pour olive oil over it.
Let that warm up, and then
you set it to the side.
And you just let that all
kind of steep together.
And that's how
you get curry oil.
So this is just curry
oil and lemon juice.
That's all this
is, really simple.
We just drizzle just
enough to coat everything.
You don't want it to be soupy.
And then this here is
just ricotta cheese,
a little bit of cream to thin
it out, a little chili flake.
Now, chili flakes add a
little bit of spice to it.
If you don't like that
spice, don't use them.
You just want to thin this
out, a little bit creamy.
And we season everything.
Now salt is kind of--
it's a great tool.
You don't want food
to taste salty,
but salt helps bring
out the natural flavors
of most any food.
You won't taste the salt.
It doesn't have to taste salty.
So a little bit-- and again,
if you don't like curry,
don't use curry.
You can just use lemon
juice and olive oil.
If there's another
spice that you like,
like cumin or coriander
might work really
well in this, if you
want to mix up the spice.
There's no rules.
The food police will not
show up and arrest you
if you use the wrong spice.
So to plate this out
like this, it's so easy.
We just a little bit of ricotta
on the bottom of the plate,
spread that around.
And that's going to be
the base of the salad.
And then in here we have
our pumpkin, our frisee,
and our dressing.
And we season it with
a little bit of salt.
I normally season
with salt and pepper,
because pepper's a
little bit spicy.
And since I have the chili flake
in here, I held back on that.
I just don't want too much
heat or spice in there.
That might fight with
the other flavors.
So then we just to build
it a little bit high.
We want it to look confused
but organized, as we say.
Then our toasted seeds,
and we just-- over the top.
And then if you're really
trying to impress somebody,
make it fancy.
We just drizzle a little bit of
vinaigrette around the outside.
And if you notice-- I think,
one thing about this dish
is it has all those
earth tones that
are associated with
autumn, the orange pumpkin,
and the toasted brown
seeds, and the yellows,
and in the deeper greens.
I mean, that looks
like fall on a plate.
So that's really it.
So that's what our sugar
pumpkin salad with toasted seeds
and curry looks like.
We're going to taste a bunch.
SOUS CHEF: [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY SEWALL: Sure.
Great, come on up
and try these, guys.
Do we have forks?
OK, so we're going to do-- the
next thing we're going to make,
it's really simple.
We're going to make a crab cake.
Again, I think it's a
really simple recipe.
It's in the book.
I think it's something
that's really doable.
It's not that bad
to make at home.
This is a great
holiday one, if you're
cooking around the
holidays, because you
can make these a
day ahead, Keep them
in the refrigerator
for a day or two.
They keep really well.
Once they're made, they're
pretty easy to serve,
so really easy.
But really what it
starts with is-- this
is Jonah crab meat, which
is a local crab here
to New England, usually northern
New England, from the Cape
up to the Gulf of Maine.
Gulf of Maine and up towards
Canada is where most of them
come from.
And it's one of the smaller
commercially-caught crabs.
When you think of crabs, you
think Alaskan King crab--
what's that show,
Deadliest Catch.
Those are what most
people think of crab.
So those are sometimes
six feet across span.
These are called
Jonah, or rock crabs,
which are about this big.
And it's a little bit more
work to get the meat out
of the shell than it
is in the larger ones.
But it is local.
It is really good.
I always encourage people to try
to source out fresh crab meat,
instead of-- and you can make
this with most any kind of crab
met.
But if you buy pasteurized
or anything like that,
generally, you lose
some of the flavor.
It gets a little watery.
So this time of year in,
especially food shops and fish
markets, fresh Jonah
crab meat is available.
So it's just really simple.
I picked it for shells,
squeeze the moisture out.
So we just have some dry,
straight-up crab meat here.
We're going to mix in a
little bit of mayonnaise.
This is just chopped cilantro.
And again, if you don't
love cilantro, don't use it.
Use an herb that you like,
like fresh dill, or chives,
or rosemary, or parsley.
Anything like that is
really good in there.
This is just a little red bell
pepper and red onion minced up.
We use a little bit of that.
An egg, and I'm not
going to quite use
the whole egg, because
it's just a small batch.
But egg is just really
used-- is a little bit
of a binder to hold
it all together.
A little bit of fresh lemon
juice, a bit of lemon zest.
So if you don't have one of
these at home, you should.
It's called a microplane.
They come in fine--
fine grating like this.
And they do bigger ones.
This is great-- great for kind
of zesting fruit really easy,
and then grating cheese
over the top of stuff.
If you burn your toast,
if you run this across it,
it cleans it right up.
In our kitchens--
don't tell anyone.
It's our secret.
But if you burn a piece
of fish on the edge,
you scrape this across the
burnt edge of the fish.
It cleans it right up.
It's a pretty cool
tool to have around.
And we seem to go
through a lot of them,
because I'm always
looking for one.
So a little fresh lemon
zest really makes it bright.
And then this is just Tabasco.
And this is just-- Tabasco
is high in vinegar.
So it's a vinegar sauce.
So it adds acid, which
like salt, kind of helps
flavors pop out and
a little bit of heat.
And I don't want it to be
hot, but I just-- a little bit
of heat in the
background there will
help develop some of
the other flavors.
You never want to
taste the Tabasco,
but it should be in there.
A little salt, we
mix this together.
So really what it
is-- it's about 50%
crab meat, 55% crab
meat, and then 45% to 50%
of everything else combined.
So it's really at least
half or more crab meat.
All mixed in there.
It's a little bit
wet, but that's OK.
It's seasoned well.
Everything's in there,
nice proportion.
And these are panko
breadcrumbs, which
is just-- they're
sold everywhere now.
When I started
cooking years ago,
only specialty stores had them.
It's just a Japanese white
breadcrumb, really versatile,
really easy to
find, easy to use.
We just fold in a
little bit, until we
get the consistency of the
crab cake that we want.
So where it's moist
but not sticky,
and it'll still hold together.
And again, if you don't like
peppers, don't put peppers in.
If you don't like Tabasco,
don't put Tabasco.
Sriracha's really good in there.
I really encourage people-- when
you're cooking at home, just
do stuff that you like.
Follow a recipe.
So maybe sometimes you
understand how something works.
But after that, make food
that you want to eat.
OK, so you can see
it coming together.
And that's about right
where we want it,
where it's still--
it's coming together.
It's a little damp to the
touch, but it's not sticky.
Let those breadcrumbs soak in.
And then this is-- it's
called a ring mold.
And every kitchen
has a gazillion
of these thrown throughout
the kitchen, different sizes.
This is what you make
things-- it's really easy.
This is a great thing to use,
because you get the right size.
And you want everything-- one
of the most important things
in a restaurant is consistency.
So if four of you were
eating dinner in a restaurant
and you all order the crab
cake, and one was bigger
than the other, everyone
would be like, what's that.
So this is built for
speed and consistency.
So I know when they're
making crab cakes at work,
they know to put breadcrumb in,
fill this thing up, breadcrumb
on top, and it's
the same every time.
So that's one of
our little tools.
A little breadcrumb
in the bottom of this.
We just pack the ring mold.
Really push it down so
it all comes together.
Then we do a little
breadcrumb on top.
There are some recipes
where you bread crab cakes.
That's a different process.
That's where you
take the crab cake.
You roll it in the flour.
Then you roll it in eggs.
Then you roll it in breadcrumbs.
And you can do that too,
and they come out wonderful.
This is just a little easier.
And I love-- I think the
best part about crab cake
is the crab.
And sometimes if you have
too much breading on there,
you don't get
enough of the crab.
So I just bread
the top and bottom
and get that nice and crispy.
So it's crispy on the
top to bottom, hopefully.
And then you have a nice,
creamy, crab middle.
So that's really it.
And then we try not to burn it.
So I got this a little hot.
Vegetable oil, or
canola oil, really
is what you guys should
cook with at home.
Don't cook with olive oil.
So if you buy a nice
olive oil-- olive oil
is not meant to be cooked with.
So it's called-- you can see
how you see that smoking.
So that's called a
flashpoint in oil.
So if oil gets too hot, and
it starts to break down,
the flavor start to really
change, is when it's smoking.
Olive oil isn't a meant
to be cooked with.
It's meant to be made dressings
with and drizzle over the top.
Because olive oil-- if you
ate a spoonful of olive oil,
it has a unique flavor.
It's pleasant.
It's meant to be
eaten on its own
or dressed over
top of the stuff.
Vegetable oil, not so much.
It's meant to be cooked with.
So the temperature
can get hotter.
I'm just going to
let that get crisp.
Oh my God, that's so easy.
So you see-- just nice and
even, so enough oil in there
where the entire thing's
coated on the bottom.
Get a nice, crispy crust.
And what I would do-- when
you're making these at home,
at this point, from there
you throw in the oven.
You flip it over,
you've got a nice brown
on top, nice even,
beautiful golden brown.
You throw in the oven.
It'll brown on the bottom,
and it'll warm through.
If I brown it on the
stove, on both tops,
it'll be hot on the top
and bottom and crispy.
But it'd be cold in the middle.
So from here, in the
oven for a few minutes.
Let it get warm all
the way through.
And you're ready
to go, super easy.
I know everyone's going to
go home and make crab cakes.
I can tell.
Let that cook another second.
So one of the things we've
paired this with in the book
is we did squash.
And I think in the book,
it's Hubbard squash.
I don't remember every last
detail of every recipe.
But I remember most of them.
So Hubbard squash
is a local squash.
It's kind of a
funny shape to it.
It's called an
heirloom squash, which
means a really old variety.
Most of the squash that
you see in the store
are your typical butternut
squash or acorn squash,
which look like a large acorn.
Just never buy those again,
ever in your entire life.
Just promise me that,
if you'll do one thing.
There's so many more
interesting, flavorful squash
out there in the world that
just have an amazing flavor.
I mean, you could do this--
and we do a little squash puree
with this and pickled chilies.
If you did this with
pumpkin, or Hubbard squash,
or there's these big funky
ones called Long Island cheese
pumpkins, amazing flavors.
All kinds of stuff
out there that
have much better
flavor than butternut.
They have this rich,
deep, earthy, fall flavor.
They're amazing.
Nothing against butternut,
but there's lots of cool stuff
out there.
It's really simple.
If you think about fall,
think about fall flavors.
As the weather
turns cold-- and boy
we've had a really mild
fall-- but I mean, for all us,
what you want to eat, and
what you kind of-- it changes.
You start to crave
things that are warm,
and hearty, and nurturing.
And these are some
of those things that
make you feel really
good about eating.
And in the summer,
you crave tomatoes,
and you crave corn
and all those things.
In the fall and the
winter, the colder
it is and the more
the weather changes--
that's kind of unique
to New England.
And that's what we talked about
in the book, how as the seasons
change, you want to
eat different things.
And as a cook or a
chef in a kitchen,
you want to cook
different things.
You get to work and use
these different things.
And that's-- there's season's
everywhere, obviously.
But what happens in New
England is truly unique.
It's a region that's so
defined by the seasons.
And we're so defined to
what's available to us
throughout those seasons.
So these are just
some-- and what
we do is we talk about, in the
book, the guys who grow stuff,
who brew stuff, who catch
stuff, and how that ties back
to the restaurants and
how they bring it to us.
And how that
changes what we cook
and eat throughout the year.
And this is just a couple
of small examples of that.
So please grab a crab
cake and try one.
And hopefully they're not bad.
Well, thank you, guys.
I'm going to hang out
over there and sign books
for a few minutes, if
anyone's interested.
And i thank you,
guys, for coming down.